also joined up with the original
accrington pals back in what was it 1914
when they were recruiting as times gone
on ease is ended up at eat and he was
killed on the twenty-ninth of sep tember
1918 cath Holmes great uncle Walter was
one of several hundred men who
volunteered for a battalion that would
become known as the accrington pals the
nickname was that was the Powell's
because they were literally powell's
together they work together and they
enlisted and served together and it was
in response to kitchener's call up in
February 1915 the battalion received an
emotional sand off in accrington
hundreds were destined never to return
it seems impossibly tragic to realize
now seeing that footage that so many of
those men who were taking the route down
Church Street were actually at the
beginning of a very short journey a
journey that was very soon to lead to
their deaths accrington will perhaps
forever be associated with its powell's
the death of so many volunteers had a
profound effect on the Lancashire
milltown both then and now at the end of
the war there were so many widows so
many women who'd lost their husbands the
brothers do fiance's friends cousins
there was barely a street that was
untouched almost every street had houses
where the blinds were drawn as a mark of
respect as well as this and what the
widow's had widows nights very little
money to live off they had to suffer the
indignities of the means test in order
to get some money to bring the families
up it was a terrible time for them a
banner stretching through the town
centre is just one of many reminders of
events that shaped the world and
continues to shape the communities we
live in today I think it was on Facebook
or saw a picture of it being part way up
so I just run when I saw it all the way
into town just come another look at it
really proud it's been
everyone was it 18 months in the making
and I just stood there crying
it's quite overwhelming Mike McCarthy
Sky News accrington